hey how important for you because I I
always I I feel like there's a guy like
uh G-Eazy right who probably
commercially outside of MC hammers run
is probably like commercially
like the biggest guy to represent the
Bay right I'm not talking about
influence or or tenure yeah I just mean
like you know representation yeah I
understand she's got songs with Britney
Spears and right um but he was like very
adamant about every tour was like from
the bait of the universe and he would
bring like I am Sue or he would bring
kailani on the road right he would bring
40 on the road
um how like like how big in the
landscape of the bay do you look at like
a guy like G and like you know it seemed
like he was doing a lot to try to do his
best to give back
um shout out to easy salute to G-Eazy
um I don't have no problem with the easy
the thing is is
um
that's 40. yeah that's kailani look at
the names you name but it was keilani
was it was it was like early K line okay
okay
for sure all black all black he did all
black I just finished Netflix on the
road with him a lot I just feel as if uh
you should embrace that more you get
what I'm saying not uh like I said not
just
um let [__] smooch off you but Embrace
that [__] more like you know like
do more of that you get what I'm saying
like do more of that like salute to you
what you got going on but do more of
that so you would like to see him do
more yeah for sure [__] yeah right [__]
yeah hell yeah but and then too it's
different genres like
he make more music like on soon he's got
pop pop music pop house music type [__]
yeah pop he's got pop records what is
house music anyway
like house music what the [__] is that
it's a genre of electronic music
whatever yeah he got that type of [__]
going on no no house is not techno but
it's the he don't make house music but
he makes top 40 more he does have top 40
records for sure yeah yes you know right
yeah
I hear it sounds like um I never like
heard of G-Eazy album but right like to
[__] with me and get some money all that
type of [__] right and people are all
black on a record yeah for sure yeah you
know yeah yeah for sure for sure oh
Black's dope as [__] too super dope
super dope yeah for sure I like um
all black Cadence and [__] he be
different with that [__] for you like
um what is like your like I know you
you've been dropping like tell me kind
of what's going on with your music [__]
right now like what's the latest what's
coming from the last project I put out
was the book of dialogue it did uh it
did very well but
um I had got over powered by the little
Blood TV type [__] right you get what
I'm saying um and I was just telling my
boys like damn I need to jump back in
the lab right like uh because I've been
focusing so much on this and it haven't
had me in the studio mode I mean I can
go to the studio and record a song
that's not that's crazy but I'm saying
in that artist now where you're like
fully engaged and you're yeah yourself
yeah yeah and you just like you in that
space to record and I tell people all
the time it's a difference from
um
it's a difference from rapping and just
being in that in that space right I'm
saying you could go write a verse if
someone wanted to buy a verse offer you
go knock that out I can go do that in 10
minutes but if you want to like put out
an album
I'm working with the mechanics have you
ever heard of them you haven't heard of
them yeah yeah shout out to uh dot dot
and tweet for Rex and tweet I'm working
with them right now we uh been in the
lab for like the last couple of months
and we got a great sounding project like
I'm hella excited about this project
because every time I went in the studio
I was in the studio mode you were like
locked in I was locked in and um
sometimes [__] will be in there for six
seven hours and just do a song and a
half are you writing [__] down yeah yeah
right yeah yeah all right and uh you
know because you know the new the new
the whole new era is all punching in
it's punching in I do I do that
sometimes too but this project I'm
writing I feel like if you're gonna do a
Melody it's like smart to do the melody
first then you kind of fill in the lines
yeah if you're gonna do a verse you know
I think punching in to get you lazy
because sometimes you'll just be like
okay let me hurry up and I mess with
that and you get what I'm saying there's
not as much thought as yeah when you
write write it down yeah you like you
all you tweaked out you hyped out like
yeah yeah for sure I would prefer
writing over punching in I wish more
rappers would like that yeah I prefer
right because you hear it
because you'll hear guys who say they
write and you'll hear it you'll be like
oh I hear like you're actually every
line matters a little more right but
look though I had got so caught up in
punching in to when I write I'll have to
take blood I couldn't wrap the whole 16.
like I had to rap like four bars and
instead of breath like what the [__]
right right so I had to retrain myself
to get back in there because normally I
can write like I used to do 30 something
bars like a whole song I can guess all
songs just reading it like you know yeah
but that punching in [__] that [__] [__]
you up so many ways yeah yeah it kind of
fuss with you I think it might be
affecting people's performance too
definitely definitely you're you'll see
artists the new artist they'll do like a
part of their verse and then they'll let
the track do the rest right right right
it's the same [__] you don't have the
breath control because they don't have
to do that [__] in the studio anymore so
have you ever heard of the hieroglyphics
of course I love Hyrule okay um shout
out to casual casual my boy and um
casual was telling me uh
well I was performing at Hyrule day and
uh the music My lyrics were playing
behind you feel me like that's [__]
like oh yeah that that would definitely
be some like OG backpack rapper [__] to
say
never supposed to rap like that like
but now everybody does it yeah for sure
for sure or you gotta have the TV track
where like parts of the verse are in
there or you're out yeah that's better
but I understand what he meant by that
like just rapping over your voice and it
sounds way better when you're just
rapping over the instrumental yeah it
sounds like you're at a show it sounds
like you had a show for sure for sure
for sure yeah shout out to Hyrule man
they kind of revolutionized a lot on it
and they're from Oakland too and they
did so much on the merch side yeah yeah
and still doing it um I think Souls of
Mischief they just got like a [__]
crazy tour 300 [__] shows or
something yeah they got they they could
tour I mean Dell shout out to Dell was
Dale from Oakland I don't know how funky
what's your name yeah I think I think so
I think it's from Oakland yeah yeah
shout out to Hyrum so yeah we got some
cats from Oakland man I'm getting it for
sure no two shorts and you know oh like
two shorts my [__] one of my
favorites ever so yeah we got some cash
from Oakland for sure Tony Tony we got
cats from Oakland